barbarbar
[Silence]
allahar ill
as
[Silence]
Sal
fbar ill
[Silence]
alhamdulillah ald
sub
[Silence]
m
my dear brothers respected
Elders beloved youth brothers and
sisters we thank Allah subhana tala for
keeping us alive one more day on the
path of Islam on theim allowing me and
you to enter his house and worship him
in the manner that pleases him I ask
Allah subh accept from me and accept
from you the little we do in his path a
mean and I bear witness there's no deity
worthy of worship except for Allah
subhana and Prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam is his last and final
messenger for surely who Allah subhana T
choose to guide then can misguide and he
choose to misguide guide him back to the
path and we seek refuge in Allah from
darkness of ourselves e and evil of our
Deeds for Allah is all knowing and
allseeing what his creation
does I thought it was best fit to to
talk about a Hadith in the light of the
last sermon that I gave last week about
having our UST in Allah subhana tala and
and believing in him in in that that we
are created as a weakling in our
creation the creation of a man indeed is
weak so the Hadith I I want to mention
is and I don't think I've done a just
based on a Hadith before so this would
be interesting for me and you inshallah
it's a long Hadith and that's why I
chose it to be part of the it's a Hadith
that is mentioned IM has mentioned it on
the number two in his book right after
the the Hadith on the
intentions and the Hadith usually
labeled as Islam
andan so the Hadith was mentioned on the
authority of
[Silence]
so is laying out the groundwork for this
person who seems to be appeared out of
nowhere the man has manifested himself
literally out of a thin air he says this
man shows up at the Masid as where theam
is with the sahab and he here is jet
black and it's blacker than the usual
his clothes are extremely wide and he
does not look he has traveled from
anywhere now look going back to the time
of if you traveled from somewhere your
convenience is not a car or or enclosed
vehicle so you're out in the open you
know to to at the at the mercy of the
elements right you're in the desert
you're traveling so of course he's
mentioning these things and then he goes
on
says nobody knows us nobody from amongst
knows who this man is so it's not like
he lives down the street he lives the
next door open
so where is he coming from and why is he
so in pristine condition if he's a
traveler from
outside and then he
says to me to me just the the amount of
of detail that he mentions is always
impressive and I think those who have
heard me give a a a a on a a ex Jesus on
this before it's the it's the it's the
picturesque moment so to speak that that
the prophet is sitting on the floor with
his legs crossed crisscrossed and this
man comes and sits directly in front of
him in the same manner but not only that
he then takes his hands and places on
his thighs knees area so to
speak right so the detail is just
Immaculate and I want to mention that
part is that it has that La Factor so
here is a man because the sahab used to
say besides
abak nobody dared have the ability to
look up to wasallam because they were
always in awe and he looked back at them
and and the amount of detail in this
Hadith is amazing this man comes out of
nowhere nobody knows him and then he
proceeds to sit directly in front of him
with almost his knees touching and then
he takes his hands and places upon his
thigh and the and the knee
area so the bedwin that used to come
tohi wasallam the the the people that
were in the desert they came up most of
the times they were not accustomed to
the manners that were in the in the in
around thei wasallam that would come and
they would always act in a weird
way and in this sense this man is doing
the same so the idea for these people
who are looking at him is that this man
is not from the surrounding area so he
says oh
Muhammad teach me about Islam what does
Islam
mean he says teach me what does Islam
mean soam gives him the Crux of the
religion in literally one sentence he
says that you bear witness there is no
God but only one God Allah and then
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam is
his last and final messenger and then
you establish the five daily prayers and
then you give arms from your your money
with Ramadan you fast the month of
Ramadan and you can make the pilgrimage
which is during the Hajj time not omra
pilgrimage once in your lifetime if
Allah has given you the
ability and to me that is the most
beautiful thing that he says to this man
I want to finish the next next sentence
and I'll come back to
it so the man who's asking the question
that returns back to says back toam the
prophet he says you're telling the truth
so Omar says now we are confused he's
asking the questions but then the
question his anwers that he tells them
you're telling the truth I mean if you
if you ask a question what does it mean
you don't know it if I know it why would
I ask a
question right so this man is asking
questions and and and having the
conversation withu Al wasallam so the
Hadith itself and most of you have of
listen to the Hadi before I've heard it
before inshallah is known as the Hadith
of
J the the the Archangel Gabriel this is
the Hadith on his name but most Scholars
have named this Hadith also as
just like
is this is named as the foundation of
the Sunnah meaning that the foundation
of what we are practicing so to speak so
there's a famous narration of Al wasam
it mentions that one dayam was traveling
with his companions outside of
Medina and a a a bedwin who is on a on a
camel disheveled and looks he's
been lost for days comes upon the party
ofat and he asks where is the road to
Medina so wasallam looks at him and he
says what do you have to do in Medina
meaning what's your business in Medina
so he says I'm looking for a prophet
that has come to Medina and I want to
talk to him so he says today is your is
is is a blessed date for you I'm I'm the
prophet that you're inquiring about what
is it that you ask so he says now pay
attention to this this is a bedwin
meaning that that he has
nothing illiterate so to speak so he
says teach me how your lord has taught
you andam gives him verbatim the same
thing that when jiel is asking him he
gives it to
him and the man says to the prophet
sallallahu alaihi
wasallam he does not even
say
M I believe you you're selling the truth
this is too much this is too little I
can do this I cannot do this he just
literally says I agree with what you
have told
me end of the
story and the man enters into the fold
of Islam on
that admission not only that soon after
that he dies and he's entered into
Paradise because of the admission in if
we have time tonight or tomorrow
tomorrow we'll we'll discuss that that
Hadith in detail I want to get to the
Hadith because there's certain part I
want to get to it and that's the main
topic that I want to
discuss what is
Im so he says teach me about IM about
about my belief what is the belief
system he says the prophet says that you
believe in Allah a monotheistic
way and his
angels in all the books that Allah has
revealed there's a caveat on that one
I'll come back to it and all the
prophets that came
before and the day of
judgment and then you believe in
predestin
from Allah
subh as as part of our saying muhammah
as being a Muslim those are defaults
that we agree with anybody who says I
don't agree with that or I don't believe
in that is not a Muslim and that's not
my theory this is what our religion
tells us if somebody says I don't
believe in the Angels well that takes
out part of your your your belief system
and says I don't believe in the books
that came before the Quran when again
that's not part of the system we we
accepted as now we do agree with the
books that exist today in the matter
they exist they have been tampered with
so we don't take it as a whole sum at
the face value we don't take it at the
at the face value of that and
then believing in all the
prophets you know understanding
Abraham Moses Jesus all were prophets
that preached the same message and had
the
same message to be delivered to the
folks to the people on the Earth that
Muhammad sallu alaihi wasallam did SOI
wasallam did not bring something that
was out of the ordinary when when he was
a
prophet and then of course predestiny
everything good and bad is predestined
is from Allah subh tala of course there
are certain things we can do to avoid it
but ultimately that's the will of Allah
and that's how the things roll so he
says now this is the part I want to
focus on
today so once again he replies back toam
he says you said the
truth and then he
asks so teach me about what
is that's
it and I think that's the definition
that exists ofan that does not exist
anywhere else regardless of how much you
look for it so he says teach me about
what
isan what is
excellence and he says to worship your
God worship your lord in a way that you
see him and if you
cannot achieve that level then have this
level that he sees you in all conditions
and that's the part that we need to
focus on as part of our daily
practices that's the part I feel that we
lag on when we talk
about the
Excellence says you know to to to
defines in a sense he defines it as to
return something that you got but in a
better
manner
right so
so you know somebody gives you a present
right you take that present and then you
give them something that is better than
that right what we're taught simple
we're taught what if somebody says asum
what do you
reply so that's you're adding on to it
to give it back to them in a better and
a beautiful
way right
that's literally the Crux of the
definition and why is it important then
when J asksam these questions why is it
important so the commentators have
mentioned that wasallam had by the way
uham used to say to to sahab ask me
questions about your religion ask me
questions about your religion get those
questions answered so you can perfect
your religion you can perfect your
religion but out of the the the the
sheer respect of wasallam they would
never approach these questions they
would be afraid to ask this questions
famous narration and I'm not going to go
into the detail of the
narration has an issue to ask about
himself there's something of an issue
that he needs to ask on a question but
he cannot muster up the courage who's
Ali come on he's the son oflaw ofi
wasallam right not only that wasallam
said You know that if the the the the
city on the city of knowledge he's the
door to
it he cannot muster up the courage to
askam directly so he asks one of his
friends he says hey here's the here's
the problem that I need to ask can you
go askam see what he answers and then he
he sits in the crowd hiding and listens
to he answer has answered
him so these people have in months
immense respect and they're under a lot
of stress from that factor that they're
not Direct asking so Allah subhana
tala had sent the the
angel who came and asked this question
on on behalf of the Muslims and you find
that when know when you when we finish
the Hadith out and the latter part of
the Hadith it
mentions it mentions this
part that who this person is because
people don't still don't know who it is
so Imam Nai says this is the this this
time when
this has come and ask the questions it's
right before the
time wasam goes for so it's literally in
the last time of his life that he's
alive so he's asking the sahab ask me
the question ask me the questions ask me
so I can I can perfect it for you I can
perfect it for you I can answer it for
you let you know what those issues
are but under the due due stress of
course you know this is the the the this
is the the prophet
wasam you know I remind folks who go who
go to to Medina and I advised some of
them I said look you know when when you
when you go to to the Masid nawi and you
walk out of Masid nawi do not throw your
your your your shoes on the floor put
them down gently CU Allah subh has said
you know if if you raise your voice
above the voice of prophet sallallah
alaihi wasallam I will destroy all of
your actions so that's his last resting
place even when you walk walk with
respect you know I share a story and I
conclude with this inshah you know I
took my dad not too long ago and and you
have to make an appointment on the app
now and you have to scan QR codes and
there were some issues and people were
pushing and shoving and my father got a
little anxious and he was trying to rush
and I and I held his hand out I said
stay back relax he said but people I
said no no relax we'll get there and if
we don't get there it's okay we're not
we're not in that Rush we're going to
get there we're going to walk there
slowly we're going to take our time
we're going to we're going to have be
respectful and once we get there we're
going to sit down
quietly and then once we're called upon
we'll do it and I swear to Allah subhana
tala those people who rushed before us
they it was time almost time for the
Salah they were kicked out before that
from that time and when we were a
shardan into the the area of the of the
Jenna the the piece of paradise there
that's right in front of the we were we
were held there from the time before the
Adan was called out until after the
Salah was over so we actually got more
time to spend in that area
alhamdulillah so respect is the main
component of it once again in it is it
is the fact ofan and let me conclude
with this Allah subhana tala has
mentioned and one according to one of
the sahabah the most beautiful places
Allah subhana he said when you read this
Ayah when you read this Ayah this gives
you the most this gives me the most joy
in Allah subhana taala this gives me the
most comfort in Allah subhana tala so
they asked him what is the Ayah he says
Allah subh mentions
in he says this Ayah gives me the most
comfort in Allah why because this Ayah
tells you regardless of what your
achievement is andan I'm talking about
the top tier level right I'm talking
about the VIP class I'm talking about
that
class that you know you know when you
get to the airport right don't you don't
get to the lounge right we're talking
about that kind of class we're talking
about that upper upper
Crux he says even though we cannot
achieve that but Allah is responding to
us by
saying he will return your he will
return your sincerity with his
sincerity this is this is a human
sincerity right you know one day I like
you one day I don't you right this
is our this is these are human beings
right one day the person wants to talk
to you the next person I want to talk to
you but this is your
lord who has created
us and when he responds or when he
returns there how beautiful would that
be so I remind myself and you as we're
present today is that when
we continue from today on
to be in that best beautiful state every
time we meet somebody we give the better
of
it I ask Allah subh to guide my Affairs
and guide your Affairs that are better
the path
[Silence]
ald can I F request you guys move
forward I see a lot of empty spaces so
just just scoot forward please to that
space fill that up we're getting full on
the back
there is a there is a beautiful
Hadith
mentioned one day is talking
to the the giant
of he
says he says I'm giving you I'm giving
you a reminder to follow I'm giving you
something you should not let
go
so wonders what it is he says after
every
Salah and for some Scholars a differ
opinion is it during the Salah or is it
after the Salah and that's something we
can discuss later inshallah there's not
time for that he says do not leave the
Salah until you make this Dua and what
is the Dua he says
he says make this Dua every single time
you pray
anything what is it
ask oh Allah make me from the person
make me from the people who are remind
who are making
your make me it's almost put me in
charge as a person to perform this act
what are those
acts let me let me be the person who
remembers you
often and I and I give thanks to
you right and it's not by the way saying
thanks it's saying alhamdulillah we have
confuse thanks thanks Shar thanks is to
some person who returns that to you I
know you know a brother is here you know
if if you know I'm going to pick on F
in Fahad is here you know if I give
something do something nice for Fahad
thank you I'm mad at now right it's a
transactional deal alham is almost it's
a it's a deal that you thank Allah
because there is no way that he needs
that from us it's not a transactional
deal from us to Allah subhana tala it's
a one-way Street for us only so we
literally Praise Him in that man
alhamdulillah and then the Perfection or
the Excellence of My Worship
so inshallah regardless of what side of
the of the fence you are From the's
perspective for some it is mentioned
while you're in t this is the last Dua
you make before you
sayum for some it is mentioned and you
can see the the thear is listed on the
on the on the on the chart for after
Salah and for them it says that
regardless of which way you fall on this
is the Dua I recommend for you to do not
leave because as I mentioned last week
if I remind you the Dua of the of the of
the from last week he said Ya Allah you
put me in this time in this world under
these circumstances I didn't ask to be
born in this era but then you told me to
hold on to the Rope of Allah so how do I
hold on to the Rope of Allah if you do
not help me and that's the way to ask
for help is to make
Dua so if you want to achieve that level
of and and in you ask Allah subh for
that through the means that wasallam has
told us ask Allah subhana tala to guide
all of our Affairs to have better the
path I ask Allah subhana T to cure the
illnesses in our community first and
foremost in the worldwide overall ask
Allah to make us from the people who
unite not divide we ask Allah to
make from the people who meant hearts
and not break hearts
we ask Allah subh to forgive our
forefathers and brothers and sisters and
everybody else was passed before us may
Allah Grant him with the highest abouts
I was reminded before the Salah one of
the sisters Auntie sh who has started
the new organization has passed
away we ask Allah subhana to elevate her
status as in Hereafter oh Allah we all
bear witness that he was a Muslim and a
good muslima so Grant her we ask Allah
subhana to ease her her and enter in the
paradise without any accountability we
ask Allah subhana tala to give her
family the Allah has mentioned in the
[Silence]
Quran
for forbb
[Silence]
your lines fill the gaps in between may
Allah mercy upon
us
Allah alhamd
Al
[Silence]
amen for
allahar
[Silence]
ahbar
allahar allahar
[Silence]
allahar alham
Aman
[Silence]
him for
Allah abbar
Allah
abbar
allar Allah akar
[Silence]
alayum
just reminders couple of
reminders for you guys U there is an
event in the gym tonight from what I've
understood today that they are Beyond
full so if you're coming for Isa prayers
and subsequently for anything else just
keep that in mind there'll be no more
no after H thoughts tonight there'll be
no youth activities inallah we'll
reschedule them sometime but just be
mindful they're expecting over about
somewhere in the neighborhood of 250
folks so it's going to be quite busy
tonight and the Mage so come accordingly
be prepared and then please be be
generous and park properly so others can
have some some parking availability as
well just a reminder for you guys as
well the construction is going on on
the in the extension so there was a
donation box separately from the back
the rahma school has a table setup
outside you're more than welcome to stop
by and get some information for kids and
somebody else would be interested in
that donate generously on the way out